PROFESSOR: Good afternoon
and welcome back.
I'm glad you all came back
even though there was a
problem in finding a seat
for every one last time.
I would like you to turn in the
problem set if you've been
able to do it.
If you haven't been able to do
it, that's no great problem,
but I hope you find
it mildly amusing.
I have given that problem set
out a couple of times over the
years, and I can recall one very
pale student who appeared
at my door the next morning
saying it's the first problem
set, you've only talked an
hour and I can't do it.
And then there was another group
of three who formed a
consortium to attempt to solve
the code using a computer.
They didn't get very
far either.
This is an interesting sort of
problem because it requires
you to think in a slightly
different direction than
you're accustomed to thinking,
and therefore it's a little
bit amusing.
This is not my creation, it
came from a book by a man
named Polya, the title of the
book is Mathematics and
Plausible Reasoning.
And he gives this as an example
of a problem that can
be solved only if
you think in a
slightly different direction.
I'll give you another example
of a problem from his book.
Suppose, not that the problem
arises in this era when you do
all of your graphics on a
computer console, but suppose
you had to, in solving a problem
in short notice, draw
a circle that had a diameter
of 4 inches.
And you went looking for your
pair of compasses which you
never use very often, and when
you found them, they were
rusted solid, and they
were open to a
distance of 5 inches.
OK, so there's the problem.
You have a pair of compasses
that can only draw a circle
that's 5 inches in diameter, you
must draw a circle that's
4 inches in diameter.
What sort of construction, what
sort of mapping out of
arcs that you connected together
could you do to
create the circle of
smaller diameter?
Anybody have an idea?
It seems impossible
doesn't it?
Well suppose you got yourself
a little block of wood that
had a height that was equal to
the square root of 5 squared
minus 4 squared.
And so you have one end of the
compass is up on top of the
block of wood the other end of
the compass traces out a
circle that has a smaller
diameter.
It's fairly obvious.
But what you have to do is to
think of a problem that has
poked your nose into
two-dimensions and think of it
in terms of a three-dimensional
problem, and
then the answer is easy.
So that was the sort of thought
provoking thing that
Polya presented in one
portion of this book.
OK, if you enjoyed that problem,
I have another one
for you in a similar vein.
And perhaps you'll enjoy
this one as well.
So while I'm talking, let me
pass this around, I think
there's enough for everyone.
Last time I got so caught up
with the displaying the heft
of the International Tables for
X-Ray Crystallography that
I forgot to mention entirely
that there is another text
that we will use in the class.
And this we will not need until
halfway through the
semester, and therefore I did
not feel terribly remiss in
not mentioning it.
It's a book by somebody named
Nye, and it's called the
Physical Properties
of Crystals.
And this is published by Oxford
University Press and
the publication date of the
original addition was in 1967.
This is a book that is really,
I don't think I'm being
extravagant in calling
it a classic.
It is a beautifully
written book.
The first 2/3 of it deal
systematically with tensor
properties, the particular sort
of mathematics that is
used to set them up,
transformation of axes, and
then looks at specific physical
properties and
numbers that have to be
described in terms of tensors.
This is actually the third
book in a sequence.
It was a book by Wooster that
covered things very similarly,
but the notation that was used
for the tensors was not the
modern current notation.
And then the subject started in
the form of a third book,
Woldemar Voigt.
And the title of this book is
Lehrbuch der Kristallphysik.
And this was published
back in 1910.
This is the first time
anybody had anything
to say on the matter.
It in fact is a big fat book
that contains some topics that
are not covered in
Wooster and Nye.
Nye's book is beautifully
written.
The first 2/3 of it concerns
tensor formalism and the last
1/3, which we will not touch
at all, deals with
thermodynamic relations between
different properties
that are represented
by tensors.
So I don't recommend you go out
and buy this book until
you determine whether or not you
need it because I'll try
to make the lectures
self-contained and I'll have
lots of notes and handouts.
The problem with Nye's book, and
any book that is intensely
mathematical, is that you can't
jump in on page 73 to
find the answer to a
specific question.
Because when you go there, it
will say as we showed back in
Chapter 4, now what is
he talking about?
So you go back to Chapter 4, and
Chapter 4 says, starting
with our definition of Chapter
2, and you have to go back and
read Chapter 2.
So it's awfully hard to pick
something out to answer a
specific question.
You have to really go all
the way through it.
The good news is that
Nye's book has been
published in paperback.
And it is available at the
COOP and paperback means
cheap, cheap, or relatively
inexpensive.
No books are really
cheap these days.
So we will cover material that's
in there, we'll have a
slightly different emphasis,
but the notation and the
general mathematics that's
involved is in Nye's book.
The second thing that I
mentioned last time is that
there is a very, very nice and
thorough and geometric
treatment of crystal symmetry.
And I said that's
the good news.
The bad news is that it's out of
print, so I promised, what
a guy, that I give you
a Xerox copy of the
first half of the book.
So here is the text that
we'll use in the
first part of the term.
I included at the beginning, the
table of contents, so you
can see each other topics that
are covered in the book.
We will not go through all of
the material that's covered.
There are a lot of different
symmetries to be derived, and
it turns out that if you get the
general idea and you can
summarize the results, there's
no need to derive every single
one of them.
It's nice to know that there's a
place where you can find out
how it is done if you really
have a particular question.
Did everybody get a copy or are
there a few who did not?
I made extras, OK, nobody
in need of one, great.
OK, let me now start with a
general rhetorical question.
Crystallography, as we mentioned
last time, is the
geometry of crystals.
It's the geometry of patterns
and the sorts of symmetries
that are in those patterns.
Now you might ask yourself,
why should I as a material
scientist or a physical
scientist of some sort, worry
about this stuff?
I'm not training to be a
wallpaper designer, I'm going
to do physical things.
I'm going to heat things and
measure properties, and that
sort of thing.
Well there are at least three
answers to that question.
First of all, whether you like
it or not, the arcane language
of symmetry is the
language that's
used to describe crystals.
It's the language that's used
to describe structures.
The normal thing that you do
when you're trying to describe
verbally a ball and pin model of
the geometrical arrangement
of atoms in a crystal is to say
the red balls are at the
corners of the cube, the green
balls are in the middle of the
edges, and the chartreuse balls
are sort of tucked up
inside one of the corners, but
slightly closer to 1 face than
to the other 2 faces.
The point I'm trying to make is
that is a language that has
limited utility.
It deals, it's capable of
dealing only with the simplest
sort of atomic configurations.
So there is a general language
based on symmetry theory,
based on group theory, that is
universally used to describe
atomic arrangements.
So instead of saying red balls
at the corners of the cube and
green balls in the middle of
the faces, I can say space
group 4 over m3 bar 2 over m,
atom a in position for b, m3m,
atom b in position for c, m3m.
That's what rock salt it.
And that is the way, not only
it, but especially more
complicated structural
arrangements are described in
the literature.
So this is the language of
describing such arrangements.
And finally, sooner or later,
I bet you that every one of
you will be involved with some
crystalline material, and the
first question you will answer
is what is its structure, what
is the atomic arrangement.
That's where properties start.
And you'll go a book or a set
of volumes that describe
structural data.
There's a big long compendium of
books that fill about that
much of a bookshelf which are
called structure reports.
They started a number of years
ago to compile all of the
structures that had been
determined within a given
calendar year.
They did a pretty good job
of staying caught up
back in 1915 and 1920.
And then as it became easier to
obtain such results, partly
due to the advent of rapid large
computers, they fell
further and further behind and
I think now they are about 5
or 10 miles--
5 or 10 years, miles as well.
But this is one of the places
to go to look up, without
going to the original
literature, whether the
material that you're interested
in has had its
atomic arrangement determined.
When you go there you're going
to find the atomic
arrangement, not in terms of red
balls at one position on
the cell, but you're going to
find it in terms of the
language of symmetry theory.
So one of the things I hope
you'll be able to do by the
time we finish this time
together, is to be able to go
to such literature and know
exactly what to do and where
to go to reconstruct
the geometrical
arrangement of the atoms.
OK, so hopefully you're at least
mildly convinced that
this exercise is going
to be worthwhile.
Before we continue where we left
off last time, I would
like to say a little bit about
the language in which these
geometries are described.
And we mentioned last time
without thoroughly
demonstrating why that in a
3-dimensional space there are
4 basically different
kinds of operations.
And one of these is something
that all crystals must by
definition display, and this
is the operation of
translation.
Analytically it can be described
as a mapping in
which every coordinate in a
space xyz is mapped to a
location x plus some constant,
y plus some constant, z plus
some constant.
And if you do the operation
again, this would go to a
location x plus 2a y
plus 2b, z plus 2c.
A feature of translation that
is unique to this particular
symmetry transformation is
that it has no origin.
If I have a pair of motifs
that are related by
translation, we could think of
them as being related by a
vector, magnitude and direction,
that takes this
motif and moves it
to this location.
We said that more generally we
should view these operations,
not just acting on one little
domain and space, but acting
on everything.
So this implies that there be a
infinite chain of motifs if
the operation of translation
is to be present.
Because only that infinite,
doubly infinite string is
consistent with all of space
being mapped into itself.
Like any vector, there's
no unique origin.
You could say it extends from
here to here, or from here to
here, or any other choice of
translation, provided the
direction and the magnitude are
the same in every choice.
As a result, it's not really
possible to specify the locus
of this particular operation.
It has magnitude and direction,
but no unique origin.
What we can do through a
very neat device is to
nevertheless, take some
reference point and have each
of these reference points
separated by T, and have each
motif lurking off in space in
exactly the same location and
distance from this point
that we've constructed.
And this array of abstractions,
so these
geometrical abstractions, these
points, are what are
called lattice points, and they
are a very neat summary
of the translational periodicity
of the crystal.
It is absolutely essential not
to mix up these lattice points
which are a construct that we
have created, and the atoms
themselves that are present
in a crystal.
The atoms are atoms and they're
not necessarily the
lattice points.
Another way of saying that not
all atoms of the same chemical
species need be translation
equivalent.
We'll see some examples of this
later on, so do not mix
up the atoms and the
lattice points.
When I talk about the sodium
chloride lattice, I mean an
array of points in space that
are located at the corners of
a cube and in the middle of
the faces of the cube.
If I talk about the arrangement
of sodium ions and
chlorine ions, that is the
sodium chloride structure and
not the sodium chloride
lattice.
And then last time I apologized
for usage so as not
to appear hypocritical.
Everybody talks about lattice
vibration, lattice energy,
lattice dynamics, and
so on, but that's a
misuse of the term.
But nevertheless, it is much
more musical than saying
structure energy, structure
vibration.
So we'll go on misusing the
term lattice I'm afraid.
OK, let's look at another
operation.
Here we change the sense
of no coordinate.
Let's next look at an operation
that might take xyz,
and map it into minus xyz.
This would be a situation where
if I set up a coordinate
system, here's x, here's
y, here's z.
What I've done is to take an
object that sits off here, at
a coordinate plus x, and I've
changed the sign of x so that
this object now sits off here.
This is exactly what happens
when I take something and
reflect it in a mirror.
And if that's not immediately
obvious, it just so happens,
not at all by accident,
I brought
along with me a mirror.
OK, here is one hand, and if you
look in the mirror, there
is the other hand.
It's the same distance behind
the plane of the mirror, two
coordinates have been
left unchanged.
The two coordinates within the
plane of the mirror, if that
is my choice of the reference
system, and one of them has
been reversed.
Now I'll take the second motif
out of the geometric
construct, and I'd like to point
out one very curious
feature of the pair of motifs
that's generated by this
transformation.
They're both the same
thing, clearly.
But no matter how I try, I
cannot move one so that it
coincides with the other.
And we intuitively appreciate
this difference by saying we
actually use our hands
by analogy.
We say one is left-handed and
one is right-handed, and they
are not congruent.
The fancy name that's used to
describe this relation is to
say that they are
enantiomorph.
Another term that's used,
particularly in chemistry, is
to say that they are chiral.
Which one is the left-handed
one, which is a
right-handed one?
This is what I call my left
hand, this is what I call my
right hand.
But can we distinguish them
physically, any other way?
No, these are terms that have
come in to regular use in both
our everyday language and also
in science because we use our
hands instinctively as readily
available examples of
enantiomorphs, readily at hand,
I might say to almost
make a pun.
One of the really brilliant
figures in physics was a man
named Richard Feynman.
Recently deceased, Feynman gave
a very famous series of
lectures on science at
Cornell University.
And he has one entire vector
that was devoted to the
difference between
right and left.
And he comes up with a funny
story, he pretends that the
hero of the story is someone
who's trying to communicate
with beings in outer space and
suddenly he gets lucky and he
gets a response to
his message.
And they work out a way to
communicate and eventually
they try to describe each other
to the other individual.
Well what they look like?
Well we're bipedal, and we have
two organs related by
reflection that let us sense
light and form images.
And we have an aperture through
which we ingest things
that can be metabolized.
And our circulation and body
works because we have a pump
on the left hand side
that circulates
fluids through our--
wait, I don't understand,
what's left?
So then there follows along this
course on how to define
left in an absolute sense.
How do you describe to someone
what makes your left hand
left, and your right hand
right without being
anthropomorphic about it.
So it goes on and on and on
and he gets into physical
phenomena which are
objective and
independent of a human being.
And finally he comes to the
anisotropic emission beta
particles in radioactive
decay.
And that depends on direction
relative to the magnetic
moment and that defines
an absolute sense
of right and left.
So that's something physical,
it doesn't depend on the
nature of the human being.
And then Feynman wraps up his
story by saying, if finally
our extraterrestrial being
travels to space, gets out of
his spaceship and he walks
forward to greet you and you
put out your right hand, and he
puts out his left hand, get
out of their fast because it
means he is made out of
anti-matter.
And nuclei of matter in this
anisotropic emission of data
rays shoot out the beta
particle in one sense,
anti-matter shoots out
the beta particle
in the chiral sense.
So it's a cute little story that
emphasizes the problem in
defining absolutely
left from right.
But they're of opposite
handedness that we can say.
Mirrors are interesting things
and I brought along a couple
of mirrors and they have very,
very peculiar characteristics.
And I would invite you to come
up and look at these in
private because if I hold them
up in front of you, you're not
going to be able to see what I'm
doing at all, although I
kid myself that you can, and
I walk around and show
you what I'm doing.
Here is something scientific,
it's a chemical compound
carbon dioxide, and--
OK, and if I hand this down you
can see carbon dioxide in
the mirror.
Can you see that?
Uh oh, it's not reflecting--
sorry, I didn't turn it on.
Now I think we can get it.
And is it working now?
OK, now it's working.
You can see why this is a very
special kind of mirror because
it reflects only red letters
and it leaves the black
letters unchanged.
You're going to have to come
up, I see some of you
straining your necks, you'll
have to come up and look at
that in person.
But the black letters are
completely unchanged, the red
letters are reflected
into letters
of an opposite chirality.
It's a very special
kind of mirror.
I've got another kind of
mirror that works in a
different way.
Where Is my other
piece of paper?
OK.
This is an interesting mirror
because it reflects only male
names are not female names.
This was a very topical sort of
mirror a few years ago when
there was a lawsuit.
There was a college down South
called the Citadel which would
only admit male applicants and
not female applicants.
So I claim that this was a
mirror that I got from the
Citadel because it doesn't
change the male names, but
does change, does reject or
reflect, female names.
So you can play with this
during our break.
But if I look at myself
in a mirror, I
take a look at myself.
If I wink my left eye, the
in there winks his
right eye back at me.
So I'm not really seeing myself,
what I'm seeing is my
enantiomorph.
Doesn't that shake you up?
You have never ever seen
yourself in exactly the same
way as other people see you.
You are only familiar with
your enantiomorph.
Does that make a difference?
Well I'll bring in something
that I put together and I
couldn't put my hands on.
We are very, very sensitive to
the symmetry in our faces.
And if they are reflected left
to right, you surely are going
to look different to
the other person.
And the way to see that is to
take a photograph of somebody
and cut it down the middle,
and put the two different
sides reflected left to right.
And the expression on the
person's face, and the general
spirit that that image conveys
is entirely different if you
use the one half of the face
reflected left to right, and
the other half reflected
left to right.
So think of this, when you look
in the mirror, you see
your enantiomorph and other
people see you differently.
Let me ask you to scratch
your head now.
Is there any time when, in point
of fact, you may have
seen yourself without being
reflected into the
enantiomorph?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Picture?
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
A Photograph or a TV monitor.
When you look at a picture on
television, you can read all
the signs, and they didn't
make up special signs in
reflection so that they'd
look right when they
photographed you.
So photography or a
video camera does
not change the chirality.
But I've got another way in
which I can see myself in the
exact same chirality.
And this I can't really
convince you of,
you'll have to try it.
If I put two mirrors together at
90 degrees, and then adjust
them so that I am looking
right the point of
intersection so that my two
images coincide, then I see
myself in the normal way.
If I now blink my left eye,
this guy blinks his
left eye at me too.
This is really astounding, two
mirrors at 90 degrees, if you
look at yourself right at their
point of intersection,
give you a non-chiral
image of yourself.
So I invite you to come up and
try that, that's truly
astounding.
So why should somebody in
material science or chemistry
care about chirality?
Does it really make
any difference?
Let me give you a little
experiment that you can try.
Suppose you have a little cell
on a couple pieces of
Polaroid, and the cell has a
glass front and a glass back
and you fill it with
sugar solution.
And then you pass a beam of
polarized light through the
sugar solution, and what happens
is that the sugar
solution rotates the direction
of polarization in proportion
to the thickness of solution
at the light is passed
through, in proportion to the
concentration of sugar.
The point of polarization
gets rotated.
Now that's pretty curious,
so you scratch
your head about that.
Why does that happen?
Well, maybe I'd better go
back and try it again.
And a day or two later, you
go back and you repeat the
experiment.
And once again, the point of
polarization rotates, but it
rotates in the opposite
direction.
The reason for this is that
if I was not careful in
cleanliness and there were some
little bugs lurking in
the corners of that cell and
when they sense the sugar
solution, they said wow, free
lunch, and they crawled out
And gobbled it up.
It turns out, those guys can
gobble up just the sugar of
one chirality.
Sugar is a chiral molecule.
And in fact there is a product
that's called invert sugar and
this is sugar that is all
of one handedness.
But everything in the world
around us, everything from
sugar beats to sugar cane to
other things that make
sucrose, manufacture sugar of
one chirality, not mixed.
All chiral molecules that are
produced by living organisms
are all of the same
kind chirality.
If we make them synthetically,
there's no reason to favor
synthesis of one molecule or
the opposite handedness, so
synthesized molecules are of
equal proportion in the
left-handed chirality and the
right-hand chirality.
This means that in the case of
pharmaceuticals at the very
best, you are going to use only
half of the product that
you've made.
There is a pharmaceutical
product that is prescribed for
attention deficit disorder, this
is called Ritalin, and
only one chirality of the
Ritalin molecule does
anything for you.
The other part is
just metabolized
and doesn't do anything.
But there are other much
more sinister cases.
There was a serious problem
about 20 years ago, primarily
in Europe, where a particular
pharmaceutical thalidomide was
prescribed for pregnant women,
it was to act as a sedative.
Only one chirality of the
molecule did this, the other
chirality tragically caused
birth defects.
So you have to be very careful
about the chirality of the
pharmaceutical molecule
that you synthesize.
Another example, there is--
I don't remember
the name of it.
This is something that
is taken to--
this is something called
Ethambutal which is used to
treat tuberculosis.
Only the molecule of one
handedness does this, the
other one causes blindness.
That's really a sinister
and antiomorph.
Then there's some even
crazier examples.
Ibuprofen is a chiral molecule,
and this in a most
remarkable situation is a
molecule which you're body
converts to the molecule of
the chirality that has the
intended purpose.
So here your body is clever
enough to change ibuprofen
into the molecule which is the
one that you need for its
pharmaceutical effect.
OK, so mirrors are interesting
things.
I would invite you to come up
and play with the special
mirrors that do strange things
and see yourself
as others see you.
And now I would like to continue
on in this discussion
to mention the ways in which
we can represent a mirror
plane in a graphic language.
This is what a mirror plane
does, it changes the sense of
one coordinate.
If there is a locus across which
that transformation is
performed, we would like first
of all, an analytic symbol.
Some way of indicating the
presence of that particular
operation in the pattern, and
a mirror is very descriptive
so the symbol m is used to
represent the presence of a
mirror plane in a particular
symbol.
We might want to indicate
a specific operation.
There are only two operations in
the case of a mirror plane
reflecting left to right and
reflecting right to left.
But there are other operations
such as rotation.
If we have a 16-fold rotation
axis, there is one operation
that consists of rotating 1/16
of 2 pi, another operation
that will also leave the space
invariant that's rotating 2/16
of 2 pi, and so on.
So an individual operation
is something that we
will want to designate.
And for a mirror plane,
something that is used
commonly in physics is to use
an operation sigma for a
particular reflection.
This is not done in Buerger.
If you get into reading it,
he uses m for both.
And then finally, it's going to
be convenient when we have
a pattern before us to use a
geometric symbol to indicate
in the pattern the locus of
this particular operation.
And what we use in the case of a
mirror plane is a bold line.
And that if this were the
pattern and we wanted to
indicate where the mirror plane
was, or the mirror line
in 2-dimensions that relates
those two motifs,
we draw it in thusly.
We began last time to examine
the properties of rotation,
but that's another sort of
symmetry and that is a
rotation which takes place
about a rotation axis.
The symbol that is used to
represent the collection of
operations, the analytic symbol,
is based on the fact
that the angular rotation,
alpha, has to be equal to some
sub-multiple of 2 pi.
2 pi over n, where n
is some integer.
And the reason for that I think
is quite clear, if I
take a particular motif and
rotate through an angle alpha,
if I am not rotating by some
sub-multiple of 2 pi, I'll
just go round and round and
round and I will never get a
finite set of objects that is
separated from its neighbor by
the same angular
interval alpha.
This will only happen if
alpha is an integral
sub-multiple of 2 pi.
And the symbol that is used
for the collection of
operations that is usually
embodied in a rotation axis is
n, the same n that is
in the denominator.
The symbol for individual
rotation, so we mentioned last
time we have to specify the
location of the point about
which we rotate, and we have
to indicate the angle alpha
through which we've rotated.
So A alpha will be an individual
operation, and the
geometric symbol will be an
n-Gon which has the symmetry
of the rotation axis.
So for a sixfold axis we
would use a hexagon.
For a fivefold axis we will
use a pentagon, for a
fourfold, a square, for a
threefold, a triangle.
Now an n-Gon with 180 degree
rotation is a line segment.
And that would be easily
overlooked and it's not very
aesthetic, so here we indulge
in a little bit of artistic
license and fatten out the
middle of the line segment to
get an oval with pointed ends.
And that's the symbol
for a twofold axis.
What about a one-fold axis?
One-fold axes exist anywhere,
so you can sprinkle them
around with reckless abandon.
A one-fold axis has no symmetry
at all, but that is a
very nice symbol to use for
no symmetry at all.
So symmetry 1 is the absence
of symmetry.
So it does come up occasionally
in notation.
Now if you look at what we've
done so far, we have a
transformation that changes the
sense of no coordinate.
We have a transformation that
changes the sense of two
coordinates, one coordinate, no
coordinate, one coordinate.
Rotation is interchanging the
sense of two coordinates in a
plane, and in a 2-dimensional
pattern, that's all there is.
But for a 3-dimensional space,
we have the option of changing
the sense of no coordinate, the
sense 1, the sense of 2,
or change the sense of
all 3 coordinates.
So if this is x and this is y
and this is z, and up here in
space lurks my initial motif,
if I change the sense of x,
the sense of y, and the sense of
z, namely take xyz and map
it to minus x, minus y, minus z,
what I'm going to do is to
essentially turn the
object inside out.
And if my initial one was
right-handed, I will produce a
chiral object, a left-handed
object.
This is an operation which
is called inversion.
In this operation of turning the
object inside out if you
will, is inverting it
to a new location.
And this analytically is the
exchange in coordinates
provided the point of inversion
is at the center.
The analytic symbol for
inversion is 1 with a bar over
the top, pronounced 1 bar.
And I'll have to leave to later
indication of exactly
where that notation
comes from.
The individual operation is
also called 1 bar, and the
geometric symbol that is used to
indicate the location of an
inversion center is a tiny
little open circle large
enough so that you don't miss
it, but not so large that it
might be confused with an atom
in a drawing of an atomic
arrangement.
So in this case, we would adorn
our sketch was a little
circle at the origin if that
was the point through which
the space was being inverted.
So that, ladies and gentlemen,
is our basic bag of tricks in
3-dimensions.
Let me point out that inversion
can exist in
3-dimensions only because I have
to have 3 coordinates to
play with or else I cannot
define the operation.
Suppose I have a mapping
operation xyz that goes to
minus x, minus y, minus z, and
I get rid of z to make it
2-dimensional.
Then my transformation is xy
going to minus x, minus y and
that's exactly what a
twofold axis does.
So inversion, when you throw
out the third coordinate,
looks like a 180 degree
rotation.
So you need 3 dimensions
in order to define that
transformation.
If we really wanted to go crazy,
we could go on to say
what happens in 4-dimensions?
There should in principle be
five different operations and
yes, mathematically you
can define them.
They're very difficult to draw
because we have to have some
sort of operation that take
something and pulls it out of
our 3-dimensional world.
We have no idea where it went
and then all of sudden, [POP],
it pops back into our space.
But mathematically there are
cases when you need a fourth
variable to describe the
symmetry of an arrangement.
And this generally occurs in
something called a modulated
structure where there's a
periodic change in some
variable other than the
atomic positions.
And let me give you two quick
examples without going into it
exhaustively.
One characteristic of an atom
besides its location and its
atomic mass and things like
that, is perhaps a magnetic
atom that has a magnetic
moment attached to it.
There are magnetically
ordered structures.
One of them looks exactly
like rock salt.
And I'll draw just the magnetic
cations which sit in
locations like this.
And the magnetic moment here
is up, the magnetic moment
here is up, the magnetic moment
here is down, the
magnetic moment here is down.
So what I've drawn here is no
longer the lattice and in
fact, the lattice constant of
this material looks like a
rock salt as far as the atomic
positions are concerned, but
the magnetic moments have to
be continued on in another
direction and some
extra distance.
Actually some examples of this
sort of behavior is FeO,
cobalt oxide, nickel oxide.
All of these cations are
magnetic, they have magnetic
moments which are ordered and
the unit cell turns out to be
when you take magnetic moment
into account, a larger cell, a
super cell.
There's a more interesting type
of magnetic structure
though in which the magnetic
moment is inclined relative to
some translation in
the structure.
And the magnetic moments all
lie on the generators of
cones, but as you walk along
the chain of atoms, the
orientation of the moment
rotates to different
orientations.
There is a family of materials
that are said to have cubicle
spin structures in which the
periodicity of the march of
the magnetic moment around the
surface of the cone occurs
with a period that is in
commensurate with the spacing
of the chain of atoms.
So strictly speaking, this
material does not have a
lattice in this direction, so
it's not a crystal unless you
use a fourth variable to
describe the periodicity of
the orientation of the moment.
And one final one at the risk
of carrying this too far,
here's a pattern that is based
on a square lattice.
It has a fourfold axis in it
unless I make the pattern out
of squares that are black and
white, make a checkerboard.
This is now no longer a fourfold
axis because I can't
rotate 90 degrees and leave
the pattern invariant.
So this is an example of
something called a black-white
symmetry, or a color symmetry.
And it requires more than just
4 operations to describe the
relation between one
motif and another.
We need a fourth operation,
switching of a color from
black to white, or switching it
from white to black, that's
a forth operation.
Again, within the confines
of a pattern that
exists in our space.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Does that actually
have-- so you're saying it
doesn't add value to
the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: I did say no
rotational symmetry if it has
a fourfold axis here but this
used to be a fourfold axis,
and that now changes into
a twofold axis.
And then I have the problem of
describing how this square is
a square exactly like this
square except for its color.
So I need then an operation
which rotates 90 degrees and
switches from white to black.
And then rotates 90 degrees
again and switches
from black to white.
So there's a fifth operation,
a color change that is
necessary in a 3-dimensional
space or a forth operation, a
color change in a 2-dimensional
checkerboard for example.
So there are lots of nuances
to symmetry theory, it's
mathematics and the nice thing
about mathematics is it's your
ballgame, you could make up the
rules and as long as you
play according to those rules
consistently, then you've got
something that people
can't quarrel with.
OK, I think my internal clock
has just told me that it's
five minutes of the hour and
it's time to take our break.
Come up by all means and play
with the mirrors if you'd like
and we'll resume the
lecture part of our
discussion in 10 minutes.